Virginia Beach police say the gunman who
killed a dozen people appeared to have
no specific targets those 12 people were
killed at a municipal building on Friday
the shooter who worked in that building
used two handguns he had bought legally
we'll have more on the investigation in
a moment but we begin with CTM national
correspondent Jericka Duncan who's been
talking with survivors in Virginia Beach
Eureka what do they say about their
escape
good morning many of those survivors
honestly say that they can't believe
that they live to tell their stories now
the 12 people who were killed are being
remembered here near the Municipal
Building where the shooting actually
happened
one of the victims Ryan Keith Cox who
his coworkers say was known as Keith is
being credited with saving seven lives
by assuring his colleagues into a safe
office space before the gunman could
strike again more than 200 people
gathered at a church service in Virginia
Beach Sunday evening to remember the 12
victims killed in Friday's mass shooting
Bishop Ezekiel Williams knew one of the
victims
Ryan Keith Cox and called him a talented
musician he cultivated that gift and
became a phenomenal singer
then affected on so many levels I think
it's a time where it causes us to really
understand and how quick life can be
taken from you
police say engineered Dwain crowd up
opened fire on his coworkers Friday
inside this Municipal Building after a
massive police response he died in a gun
battle with officers Christie de Juarez
city employee who worked in the
Municipal Building for 13 years says
Cradock was an unassuming coworker he
smiled when you said hi to him
devar said she initially thought the
shooting was a drill she credits her
survival to colleague and friend Keith
Cox who directed her and six others to
hide inside an office and we ran in
there and I turned us to come on and he
said I'm gonna go check on other people
barricade yourself in it are the final
words you heard from your friend
yes Cox was one of eleven Virginia Beach
employees who died their combined years
of service with the city totaled more
than 150 years a contractor was also
killed people gonna describe it but
until you're actually there and you're
having to walk through that scene you
can't imagine it devar says she
experienced a range of emotions
following the violence but ultimately
she forgives the shooter and you say
that's because of Keith because of the
type of man he was
yes I know that Keith would not want us
to blame Dewayne or his parents and I
know that Keith deserves for the world
to know his heroism is I wish everybody
in the world was keith was resemblance
of what keith was all about
community leaders are urging people to
wear the color blue today in honor of
the victim saying that blue represents
the color of the ocean as well as the
color that the first responders wear at
last check there are still four people
in critical condition who were involved
in this shooting
Gale where Jericka I can't even say
thank you you look at the wall of faces
of the victims who just go to work it's
going to be another day and it's not
it's too much